[Music]
all right
we're finally here
we're finally here i think we're uh i
don't think it's too early to jinx it
but i think it's it's probably cool to
say if you're watching this
we survived 2020 together not everybody
was as lucky but congrats patched off on
the back so i know we all want to put
2020 in the rearview mirror once and for
all i cannot wait to tweet hindsight
2020 but just in the spirit of looking
back for a second in the tech world
which is what i like to talk about and
look at
tech didn't stop like it just kept going
we just kept getting events they all
went virtual they kept announcing
products we had tech timber just like we
always do there were plenty of really
good products i gave out my smartphone
awards there are plenty of not so great
products plenty of memeable tech all
kinds of stuff along the way i thought
it was a lot of fun but that being said
i think it's time to look forward
towards 2021 now first up is new gaming
consoles that came out last year are
still to this day pretty hard to get and
i think they still will be probably for
at least
a couple more weeks and that'll start
getting less crazy especially with the
ps5 probably
in like spring but if you're trying to
win one before that i am giving away a
bunch of these consoles as you probably
saw one of the last videos we're giving
away 24 of them so all you have to do to
get entered there is follow on twitter
simple as that it's a good time and i
have
big plans for this channel in
2021 not just for well for youtube for
this channel and for for youtube and
beyond in 2021 a lot of stuff being
planned you guys already know some of
the stuff like retro tech season 2 is
coming you guys already know there's
going to be coverage of tech products
but there's a lot of stuff you don't
know about
that's in the works we're actually
hiring for the first time in a long time
i post it on twitter there's a google
form
that's that's the main way we're we're
actually going to be looking through
people applying so for 2021 if you want
to join a team that's doing big things
and you actually have the skills and the
talent that applies here definitely
check that out
nice little
little boat horn
it wouldn't be 20 20 without
some noise but i wanted to end the year
with a q a it's been a while since i did
one of these uh i actually do them more
often on the waveform podcast now but
it's been a little bit i like doing
these so i asked on twitter what you
guys wanted to know
this is what you want to know all right
so austin asks how long before there's a
mass market foldable phone
that people will actually want
and can afford to buy
austin austin austin it's the classic
predictive future in the world of tech
problem i actually think honestly this
might be the thing that i am asked about
the most which is not just foldables but
what do you think the future holds for
me the best way of predicting the future
which i'm not good at by the way but the
best way to do that is to look at what's
happened in the past
so we've had
smartphones as a new form factor happen
and they were expensive but they only
took i would say like three to four
years before most people were looking to
get a smartphone and i'm talking like
2007 when these really like evolved from
the blackberry to like the iphone candy
bar style phone so i'm actually really
hoping
for
like the third generation of a lot of
these foldables
to be
the one that lowers the price like we
got the first gen where the tech is
proof of concept we get the second gen
with all sorts of refinements from the
learnings from the first gen
and then i'm hoping third gen
price drop
that's what i'm hoping anyway all right
what are your thoughts on how the viewer
can find a video for both positive and
negative reactions to a certain idea or
product
that's a really interesting question and
i think that actually comes from the
state of youtube in 2020. you see when i
was starting back in back in those days
i started to sound like an old person
when i say stuff like this but back when
i was starting youtube youtube was very
different there weren't really that many
tech channels
at all and i get a lot of credit
sometimes more than i deserve for being
first or being really early but there
was a generation of the chris pirillos
the john four lakers the soldier knows
bests the people who started before me
the ijustines that inspired all of the
tech creators that have come out since
then
and so back then if you were doing tech
carving out your niche was as easy as
just covering tech
but now since there are thousands and
thousands of tech channels on youtube i
feel like you start to see instead of
just carving out your niche as being a
tech channel that feels like it's not
niche enough and so if you want to
differentiate yourself you start to see
uh the the apple tech channel where you
see the explainer tech channel
and you see the positive tech channel
and the negative tech channel that's
there's all sorts of versions of this
that have emerged because of
what youtube has become there's just
more of it now so i think if you look
hard enough you can kind of find
whatever you want about a product you
can find the greatest most well-reviewed
product ever and the negative tech
channel will see that as an opportunity
to stick out from the rest and carve out
their niche and tell you why it's a bad
product that's just going to exist now
so i think our job as reviewers is to
tell the truth and be honest and i think
your job if i can give you a little
homework as a viewer is to watch more
than one person talk about something
then you can pick what you agree with
all right which apple product are you
most looking forward to in 2021 and why
and what do you think will be the next
big technology innovation uh here we go
again future you know i'll just answer
the apple question because i think
apple's always been interesting they
make a lot of stuff and i think we
always
hope that they'll make more stuff than
they do more different stuff
what i'm looking forward to in 2021
honestly is the new m1 max or apple
silicon max i think that's the
no-brainer the first generation of apple
silicon max was so incredible and then
the fact that they can only get better
from there
is amazing i got m1 max as gifts for
people in my life this year and i don't
think they'll regret it but i'm very
curious about like the new imac the new
16-inch macbook pro
and just the rest of that lineup oh my
god carl conrad back with the porsche
when will you finally be joining the
porsche club in 2021
carl i have no plans i love the tai can
i know you probably love the thai can
but i am a firm believer at this moment
at least for me
that the tesla model s is the best daily
driver
like he's just got the most space it's
the best performer it's got the best
software it's just
i got no reason to switch but i love me
some tycan don't get me wrong i'm just
not i'm not switching i'm also holding
out hope here's another little little
forward looking i'm holding out hope
maybe foolishly the tesla roadster is
maybe two years away actually fun fact
if you look at tesla's website right now
this is the last day of 2020 that i'm
recording this but it still says on
their site that the roadster should
start production in 2020 because you
know that's what they announced back in
the day when they announced the new
roadster but i'm thinking 2022 or 2023
is when that'll come out and if i can be
patient
and just
use my model s as a daily driver until
then then i will finally have a bonafide
electric supercar
and i won't need a tie can but you know
love me some thai can oh
ooh what are the odds you bring back
icons couldn't get everything i wanted
in the drop so i'd love the chance to
get it again
this is something we're actively working
towards i think we'll be able to bring
icons hopefully back permanently and
that's all i'll say i mean it's a it's a
collaborative effort dbrand's got to
make them and they had to make a lot so
their challenge is spinning up and
hopefully being able to make everything
they make and icons at the same time
but that's the plan not a question but
huge thank you for all the work you've
done to entertain us well thank you
thank thank you
i don't say this enough but thank you
for watching it's the reason i'm able to
make this stuff
and
it surprised me on many occasions how
many people are interested in tech and
and will watch tech videos on youtube so
thank you alright you've talked to slash
interviewed some pretty awesome people
is there anyone else on your list that
you'd like to meet or interview
that is a
fun
question
and yeah if you look at the interview
list now oh my gosh in 2020
so now it's
i mean we added some crazy people to the
list you know what's interesting though
about the
the talking tech series i originally
started this series to talk to people
who have an interesting perspective in
tech in some way
and so it's been a variety of people but
anytime you do one of these high profile
videos
what you don't know is immediately after
that in my inbox is a bunch of offers
from similar people to be interviewed in
the same way
and so when i interview a ceo for
example
i guess a bunch of other major companies
see that as an opportunity for their ceo
to come on the show so there's been a
bunch of ceos but there's also been a
bunch of other people that also have
wild creative and interesting ideas in
the world of tech and i just want to
keep that trend going so yes i've talked
to
a very impressive list of people but i
don't want to limit that list to just
super famous ceos i want it to be people
who have interesting thoughts on the
world of tech i i'll throw out the
boston dynamics founders they just got
acquired this year but when we went out
and shot that video of spot the robot
and if you saw the crazy stuff they're
doing in their headquarters now in that
same room with that video going viral of
all the robots dancing
they are very interesting people to talk
to when we shot that so people like that
here's an offer extended to them to talk
but of course many others okay now that
airpods max have been released how do
you see this affecting the premium
headphones segment in the future
well
the apple effect is very strong as we
know
and
there's already been headphones like
airpods max
but i think what we're really just
seeing is
as sad as it is to say a price enabler
like we've we've come up to that 350
limit pretty hard like if you want the
premium noise canceling wireless over
your headphone experience
and i think apple coming out with a
great version for 550
unlocks the door for maybe sony to make
a 500 pair
or maybe audio technica or maybe bose or
maybe microsoft i don't know if it's
going to happen but
that tends to be what happens when apple
does something is
following in the footsteps there oh dan
will we see an mkbhd golf video in 2021
uh
i've thought about it but here's here's
the reason so okay for those of you who
don't know i've played golf for a long
time i've played golf since i was 10
years old which means
i've been playing it for more than half
my life
17 years at this point
and i played a lot more in 2020 because
team sports were canceled there was no
ultimate frisbee there was no league to
play in and so to get my physical fix
i played a lot more golf
that was a lot of fun i shared some of
it on twitter and instagram didn't make
any videos about it
uh
and i think when we get back to team
sports maybe in 2021
i'll probably play less golf
i still want to play a lot of golf i
just know i don't think i play enough
golf to make golf videos as much as i
want to i would i still want to make we
go we'll play dan i'll play golf with
you which nba team are you reading for
this season
wait this guy's user name is
is jimmy buckets fan but also luca
harden is his username
what uh which nba team are you rooting
for now i think as much as i like
watching chris paul play he's my
favorite player to watch i don't see
phoenix being the
championship winning team this year as
much as i love him so i'm going to say
giannis and i hope the bucks actually
get a ring this year i think they got to
beat the lakers in the finals
and that's when the crown
comes in for that mvp but you know chris
paul's still my favorite player okay
interesting biggest consumer tech
letdown of 2020
that you think will be redeemed in 2021
so it's a
a pretty positive angle pretty
optimistic
redeemed biggest letdown in 2020. i mean
the biggest letdown was probably losing
the charging brick in the box of like
a bunch of flagship phones
but i don't i don't think that's gonna
be redeemed in 2021 sadly you know what
the real answer probably is there's a
vaccine everybody takes it seriously we
make a recovery and things get back to
the way they were is that a good answer
that feels like a good answer oh where's
your video about your lasik eye surgery
i
d well i didn't make a video about it
but i did get lasik uh those who don't
know i made a resolution in 2019 that i
wanted to see 2020 by 2020 which was
just a cheesy way of saying i wanted to
get lasik not have to wear contacts
anymore and i did it and it's the best
thing i ever did it's the best money i
ever spent i would recommend it to
anyone who's a candidate i was a pretty
flawless candidate as far as my eyes
were concerned i had like a minus 1.5 i
was a little nearsighted
have worn contacts or glasses and oh man
it's great highly recommended i'm not
reviewing lasik but i'm basically
reviewing it 10 out of 10 would
recommend oh i like this one
i like this one to end it
where is the dark mode version
of the intro
2021
let's say 2021 dark mode intro
committing to it now there's just so
much to look forward to there's no way
2021 isn't better than 2020. i know it
feels like we're jinxing it but
just as far as the tech we're looking
forward to in this this video i've
already talked about you know electric
cars for one roadster is probably not
happening this year but cyber truck
maybe and a bunch of other electric car
competition talked about the the apple
silicon max i think that's going to be
awesome to watch the next few
generations of it roll out new form
factors
some phone stuff
really interesting
galaxy s20 lineup or s21 lineup in
january might be a little
i mean it's going to be interesting to
watch because there's rumors flying
about some plastic 1080p
60 hertz maybe some some questionable
rumors
we'll have to see
you know ces is going to happen
and just all their phone stuff you know
oneplus 9 galaxy fold 3
surface duo 2
z flip 2
some good stuff coming up
and i'll toss in the iphone 13 lineup
because maybe this will be the year of
well a lot of things for the iphone a
portless iphone potentially 120 hertz
iphone potentially
a notchless iphone potentially i'm
hoping at least to see touch id come
back
but yeah there's just there's endless
stuff in the tech world to look forward
to it's a good time to be a nerd and
lastly
i'm looking forward to stepping the
videos up in 2021 we've stepped up as a
team the quantity of videos but i think
like i mentioned in the beginning
there's a lot more that we can do
on this platform in the in the tech
world and in the video world that is
really exciting to me so look forward to
that
yeah and then just looking forward to a
fresh new start
all right quick sponsor message shout
out to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video so now more than ever pretty much
all of our life feels like it's on the
internet right from the things that we
buy online to the videos we watch the
messages we send even the classes we
take so the big tech companies have sort
of mastered the art of tracking all of
that like the level of data collection
that's going on would probably blow your
mind
and so when you see that there's sort of
a log of your online activity being
built up it can kind of feel like an
invasion of privacy so that is where
expressvpn comes in so they're the vpn i
use and they encrypt your data and hide
your device's ip address so tech
companies can't track your internet
activity back to your location so to
hide your ip address expressvpn reroutes
your connection through a secure server
and you can choose from up to 90
different countries to route that
through which lets you browse the web as
if you're from that other country and
the bonus is also lets you get past
region restrictions on a lot of websites
so for example this weekend i realized
that elf is not on netflix in the us
which is crazy but of course it took me
15 seconds to realize it is on japan
netflix so pro tip if the christmas
experience to you feels incomplete
without elf or other movies not
available on us netflix like the grinch
or die hard you just grab expressvpn and
just switch up and now netflix thinks
you're from japan so if you don't
already use expressvpn i recommend it
and if you use my link expressvpn.com
mkbhd you can get three months free so
again shout out to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video all right so thank
you guys so much for sticking with me
for this video thank you for watching uh
lots of great stuff coming out for this
year if you haven't already subscribed
to the waveform podcast we're stepping
that up to a weekly podcast for 2021
also so subscribe anywhere you listen to
podcasts get in on the giveaway follow
on twitter all right i've plugged enough
stuff catch you guys next year
[Music]